have American Conservative Union
Chairman match slap salem nationally
syndicated radio talk shows Larry yell
elder from the hill Joe Concha Fox News
contributor former Clinton pollster Doug
Schon and Fox News contributor Tammy
Bruce right now it's 54 percent New York
Times as I mean it's a bouncing around
like a ping-pong ball and we're all
sitting here neurotically looking at all
this it really matters vote turnout
specific counties he ment mentioned
Talladega County I'd say in another
County having lived in Alabama would be
Madison County a bit of a bellwether
northern Alabama certain counties
obviously in the north Roy Moore is
going to want to run up the vote as much
as he possibly can there in the
Birmingham area some certain Democratic
areas the same with Doug Jones what you
take Kevin well look I think that that
one of the big benefits Roy Moore has is
the history and the infrastructure of
the Republican Party there has never
really been I think a competitive race
there between the Democrats and
Republicans for a couple decades
you also have then they know where
anymore they've what some things may
surprise basic Americans Americans not
in Alabama
it doesn't necessarily surprise the
people that know that man and his family
so it is about infrastructure it's about
getting out the vote
and right now Roy Moore and the
Republican Party have that edge all
right let me bring in our own Brit Hume
elder statesman he's seen a campaign or
two also a close friend of ours Brit
thanks for being with us let's talk
about the national implications for a
minute Brit I know the Republican
establishment were dead set against
supporting Roy Moore at the end they
ended up coming in the president went in
but not in the state who went close to
the state he also pointed out that for
him with the Senate margin of fifty to
forty eight going down a 51/49 becomes
intolerable and means you almost need
the entire Senate Republican caucus to
pass a bill no but so that's true Sean
and indeed the Republican leadership in
Washington remained divided over over
Roy Moore's candidates either president
and with it with him the Republican
National Committee swung behind him but
the Senate Republican leadership did not
nor did the National Republican
Senatorial Committee which is an
important source of support for any
candidate running for office so the
division there remains Sean
very great worry in the in among Senate
Republicans that Roy Moore if elected
while he would be an ally on many issues
voting would be a problem for Republican
candidates running for Senate next year
because the Democrats will be claiming
that they disposed of and disciplined
all of their alleged sexual offenders
and and here's Roy Moore who who against
whom charges are still hanging who is
accepted in the part of the Republican
Party so that's the dilemma they're
worried about and obviously they can't
win either way Shawn because either they
lose the seat or they gain what they
think may be an anvil around their necks
if Roy Moore would have pulled this out
and it's very tight according to all
exit polls and all the numbers were
seeing early on here if he were to pull
this out we know the the Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell has a 10:00 a.m.
scheduled conference with all the
Republicans there if they decide to do
an ethics investigation if they would
then aggressively go after Roy Moore and
perhaps look to overturn the results of
this election what would be the impact
the results how would the people of
Alabama feel well I think the people of
Alabama at least those that voted for
Roy Moore would be furious I don't think
there's any question about that so
that's the kind of calculation that
these Republicans in the Senate would
have to make is it worth it is he enough
of a burden to them as they seek to
maintain their majority next year that
it would be worth the candle and of
course you know this is only a special
election there'll have to be a regular
election going forward
Alabama remains an overwhelming were
whelmingly Republican state and I think
the belief among Senate Republicans Sean
is that that it had they nominated
either mo Brooks or Luther strange that
that either of those candidates would be
way ahead tonight instead of being in
this close race
that they might lose I might add Sean
you may recall back last year on
election night I kept quoting the
betting odds put together by our
colleagues John John Stossel and maxim
wah do have a website where they keep
track of these things
yeah right now they're betting odds have
more 73% Jones 26% that's what the
betting odds
right now all right let's go you may
recall the course last year when I was
what everybody was scoffing when I was
quoting them early in the night last
year and they turned that the pedagogues
turned out to have it right before
anything else I'm not saying that's true
here there were a little head of the
curve and thought Trump had a much
better chance than other people but good
to see a bridge we always appreciate it
we'll check in with you later in the
hour